what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest updates in the
dragon ball super story we got a new
strongest fighter in the world and we
got to see him in action vegeta shocked
everyone and more crazy stuff happened
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you do enjoy seeing these dragon ball
videos and want to keep them coming you
know what to do channel the same within
and smash that like button like it was a
heater remember smashing that like
button is goku energy and passing is
yamcha energy so choose wisely if you
haven't make this the video subscribe
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future dragon ball super videos and
updates and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all this
chapter is called gas's wish and it
fittingly starts with the heaters for
them it's a problem that granola has
finally stopped fighting with the
saiyans since as we saw last chapter
granola found out it was a saiyan that
saved him and the heaters are actually
responsible for death of his people and
more specifically elek is responsible
for the death of his mother alec is
surprised when he hears about the
namekian that popped up and stopped it
because he believed that monaeto knew
better than to meddle it's hilarious to
see gas he's always raring to go he's
always got his foot on the gas so to
speak once more he's pretty much just
like lemmy at him and alec is the one
that wants to be sure not trusting in
pre-wish gas to get the job done and
honestly despite how much he sucks as a
person this is a smart move by ellick
they tell elec how to find the dragon
ball and how to summon the dragon and
ellick promises to gas that he'll see
his wish fulfilled which may be to get
revenge or in some way make up for what
happened against bardock which really
seems to haunt him even to this day god
i want to know what happened there
unlike with granola gas doesn't even
think the wish is necessary and just
says he's fine as he is but ellick
insists saying it's the only surefire
way for them to achieve their goals of
course even that's not sure fire as we
saw because warriors grow while battling
and he can still be surpassed even if he
starts in the lead i wonder how they'll
handle this in terms of what the
sacrifice will be for granola it kind of
made sense he'd sacrificed a bunch of
his life because he agreed to it but it
would be kind of stupid for gas to get
his remaining lifespan sacrificed in the
same way because it was alex idea we'll
see what happens but so far gas is my
favorite heater he seems less corrupted
and more like he just wants to fight and
prove his strength and maybe that's just
because he looks the youngest rather
than greed him wanting to obey elic
comes off as loyalty so it'll be
interesting to see how this goes how
will gas respond if he finds out that
alex sacrificed gas's remaining lifespan
just so he could use him as a tool let
me know what you think about this in the
comments what will happen and who is
your favorite heater that's the 1
million dollar question we now jump back
to our guys and granola is
understandably freaking out on monaeto
because monaeto didn't say anything
granola has actually served a guy that
killed his mom you could totally
understand why he's angry and side note
but i'm still loving this arc this
granola and heater stuff turned out to
be way more interesting than i thought
it would not to mention the fact that we
got a new epic form of vegeta and more
on bardock's interesting backstory
munaito's excuse is pretty
understandable too he says he wanted
them to survive so he didn't say
anything at least pre-wish granola
definitely would have only gotten
himself killed after learning his true
history i can feel for granola big time
but it also adds to his revenge arc even
more and it's ensuring that the eventual
revenge will be all the more satisfying
just like we assumed monito does say
that bardock beat gas and he even adds
that gas was very strong at that point
and then we get a very convenient
interruption so we don't hear how he
beat him that's going to be something to
watch out for in the upcoming chapters
either bardock was stronger than we
thought or he somehow outsmarted gas
even though gas was more powerful either
way the storylines got me hooked and i
can't wait to find out the interruption
is actually the darkening of the sky
because of the summoning of the dragon
every dragon ball fan should be used to
this by now everyone gets distracted
here and it's understandable but if i
was there i'd be like yo what happened
to bardock though but oh well all in
good time we see this dragon again and
it must be noted the aesthetics of the
dragon are great however we feel about
the only two balls thing the design is
fire then we also don't get to see the
exact wording of the wish by elec or the
consequences of it this chapter is
really focusing on keeping the suspense
going and it's really working on me
personally as the sky returns to normal
we get those patterns in the back of the
panel that i feel like we got with moro
2 letting us know that they sense gas's
enormous power signature maki and oil
are shown first maki is so annoying here
and arrogant telling them that all
that's left is to take out the trash
she's smiling and giddy clearly feeling
like our guys have already been
checkmated if we got vegito or gogeta
right about now though now that would be
a checkmate but let's see how they play
it out she even pours salt on the wound
thanking granola for being such a team
player all these years wow it's really
going to be satisfying when maki gets
her just desserts just saying granola is
angry they send saiyans to kill him of
course but she says they had no choice
after he cheated to become the strongest
and i like that too that they brought up
the idea of cheating since a lot of fans
felt that way about the wish and i know
at least one person who dropped the
series because of it but i think the
saving grace is that it's being used by
antagonists rather than our main
characters who would never take such a
shortcut then maki presents them with
the universe's new strongest warrior gas
ketchum pointless pokemon reference
aside it's a pretty cool moment too
because gas has had a massive growth
spurt it kind of reminds me of gohan's
transformation in hunter hunter so you
can imagine it'll come at a cost i'm not
sure of the lifespan of these guys but
since gas didn't age much in 40 years
i'm guessing it's naturally a lot
finally goku and vegeta find out that
granola also used the balls on this
planet for a wish and it's not that big
of a reveal really but goku mentions
that that explains it why he didn't seem
used to his power the rest of this
chapter proceeds to be the gas flexing
on everyone one portion after a powerful
opponent appears we always get these
kinds of flex moments and this one is
pretty great gas scares them with a
finger laser and destroys the ship he
then proceeds to materialize a weapon
and pins granola painfully to the wall
now these guys are tired from fighting
but it's still crazy to see how easily
he just dealt with this dude who's been
flexing on our main characters for
multiple chapters things don't look good
at all which is great for suspense gas
tells granola he's never liked him and
again his immaturity comes through he
didn't like him because he felt like he
alone should be enough muscles for the
heaters so he was just jealous that they
relied on granola too he says he'll kill
granola and then goku steps in to help
but then gas uses his powers to create
heavy weights around goku's limbs so he
can't move this power looks super op
can't wait to see how they end up
dealing with it at this point gas
recognizes goku as bardock's son and
yeah how can you not it's pretty perfect
for him who wants revenge against
bardock for that mystery thing he did to
him in order to defeat him it's kind of
funny how vegeta comes in with some
useful information to answer gas's
question about bardock and says frieza
slate all the saiyans and only a few are
left gas simply says is that so at least
this dude clearly had nothing to do with
wiping out the saiyans maki as annoying
as ever chimes in that that's great and
they'll finish what frieza started even
though she would get wrecked by everyone
goku tries reasoning with him and gas is
the one to reason with if any of them
are but gas simply states they must
perish because they threaten the
heater's plan he is about to cut goku
with a newly materialized axe before
granola reveals that he's escaped by
attacking gas in the back from the looks
of it monito helped him it's nice seeing
granola trying to maintain his pride as
number one he says the title of the
strongest belongs to him but it's not
very convincing the dude is barely
standing his attack didn't really hurt
from the looks of it and gas quickly
smacks him away like a fly i'm really
enjoying this weapon materialization
ability from gas it's like he's the
warhammer titan it's fun to guess what
he'll create next and how he'll use it
so much potential with such an ability
while gas is beating up granola and
being jealous because alex saw value in
him when naito uses very useful namekian
powers to make the strong waves
disappear when it proceeds to start
healing goku begging him to save granola
goku as the pen blast ever in the face
of a seemingly impossible undertaking
says sure he'll do what he can as the
fight continues between granola and the
stronger gas we jump into a flashback of
granola's bounty hunter days when they
first heard about him and recruited him
alec first confronts monaeto who's
extremely upset at alec for showing up
here again after everything he did gotta
give it to monito he's definitely a
super nice guy it's at this point that
monito explains to alec that he didn't
tell the truth to granola because he
knew granola would just get himself
killed if he found out the truth while
seeking revenge then elect goes on to
make things very clear he says if
monaeto tells the truth they'll both be
killed alec proceeds to recruit granola
and in order to convince them he even
uses the motivation of getting monito a
better place to live with the money
they'll give him now in the present
monito is second guessing himself saying
it would have been better to die than
serve elec and honestly if that did
happen they could not use these dragon
balls to make gas so strong however i
totally get why he did what he did and
it makes for a more interesting arc
anyways it is at this point where
monaeto reveals that he can't actually
manage to fully restore goku's energy
goku points out that vegeta had a senzu
bean and vegeta simply tossed it with
his armor however he rushes to look for
it soon enough in the meantime goku says
he'll try to hold off gas and he even
tells vegeta that this senzu bean is his
because goku already ate one it finally
seems for a second like vegeta may get
to beat the villain of this arc it's
also really funny how goku says that
vegeta can transform into that freaky
face mode i love that comment of course
vegeta reminds him that it's called
ultra ego bro and calls him a fool too
these guys have such an awesome friend
vibe going on gas takes on goku and goku
actually manages to stop gas's
materialized blade and even breaks it
which is pretty cool to see as goku
super saiyan blue goes on the offensive
gas materializes a shield and uses it to
block his attacks before you know it gas
appears behind goku with a cartoonishly
large mallet and sends goku flying i'm
definitely enjoying these new powers and
the way gas is using the powers kind of
reflects gas's immaturity too like he
just saw this on tom and jerry and
wanted to try it himself maki has
another chance to be annoying surprise
surprise when saying that these saiyans
aren't tough and maybe they didn't even
need to make the gas wish i think that
statement is totally premature since
they haven't even seen the saiyans at
their full power but hey we didn't
really know what gas was capable of
before the wish either it's very safe to
assume that he wasn't as strong as
granola of course who wished to be the
strongest we jump to vegeta who finds
the senzu bean but doesn't immediately
eat it very intriguing while gas
continues to test out new weapons on
goku and goku reverts to base form we
see vegeta approach the very damaged
granola vegeta makes the truly shocking
decision of giving the senzu bean to
granola instead of taking it for himself
and a lot of people will probably be
like yo vegeta just had a chance to
shine and goku was giving it to him but
now the writer is taking it away and
giving it to granola however to be fair
it is interesting characterization for
vegeta vegeta explains that he didn't
take the sense of being against granola
because he didn't want to take the
coward's way out but now he wants
granola to have it so he can satisfy his
revenge this has been a consistent
thread running through this arc if
you've been paying attention vegeta has
really been empathizing with granola
because he's also been on that revenge
grind before he knows how important the
revenge is to granola so he tells him to
settle it with his own strength for
someone whose new form is called ultra
ego that's a very unegoic and selfless
thing to do because you know vegeta
would love another chance to fight and
push his limits it confirms that this
new form will not be causing his
character to regress into a super
selfish dude and that's where the
chapter ends honestly i really want
granola to get his revenge even though i
really want to see vegeta shine too
granola not only lost his mom and people
but even serve the people that did it
without knowing the truth that sounds a
lot like vegeta's backstory doesn't it
so it's not surprising that vegeta wants
to give this opportunity to granola and
i totally respect him more for that not
less but yeah let me know what you
thought of this chapter and what you
expect to happen next will granola get
his revenge or will we need an ultra ego
instinct fusion the fusion definitely
won't happen if it could be at all
avoided because vegeta and goku don't
like the idea but if gas is seen as a
threat to the earth too you can see them
opening up to the idea more let me know
who your mvp was for this chapter i
gotta go with vegeta loved his decision
and compassion here he seems to like
taking people under his wing like with
cabba and it seems like he's doing a
similar thing here with granola and that
is it for this video if you did enjoy
this one and want to keep the dragon
ball super reviews coming you know what
to do channel the saiyan within like
that one dude on youtube who used to try
to become super saiyan and smash that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing that like button is goku energy
and passing is yamcha energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
dragon ball super videos and updates and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you